We can simulate the collision of two black holes like a billion light years away with stunning precision.
Oh, absolutely. Down to the exact gravitational wave.
Right. But if you ask a supercomputer to perfectly model the turbulent swirl of cream being stirred into your morning coffee or even just the exact way air rips over the side mirror of your car on the highway, the computer just chokes.
It completely falls apart.
Yeah. Fluid dynamics is literally everywhere. It governs the weather, our vehicles, the blood pumping through your veins. But mathematically, controlling a fluid is, you know, one of the most stubborn, intractable puzzles in modern science.
Because it fundamentally resists our usual engineering tricks, right? I mean, when a fluid becomes turbulent, you're dealing with high-dimensional, nonlinear chaos.
It's just a mess.
Exactly. You have microscopic eddies spinning inside large vortices, and they're all interacting at the same time. Traditional control theory assumes a level of predictability that, well, it just doesn't exist in a turbulent wake.
Which perfectly sets the stakes for what we're looking at today. Welcome to today's Deep Dive, where we're unpacking a paper published in Nature just two days ago on August 19th, 2026.
A really exciting one too.
Yeah, it's titled The HydroGym Reinforcement Learning Platform for Fluid Dynamics. It's by Christian Leijman, Ricardo Vinuesa, Stephen L. Brunton, and 18 other co-authors.
Quite a massive collaboration.
Definitely. And okay, let's unpack this core problem they're solving. Their premise is that flow control hasn't been stuck because of bad machine learning algorithms. We actually have great algorithms. The field is stuck because of what they call the specificity
trap.
Yeah, the specificity trap is such a great way to frame this historical bottleneck. Because for the last decade, if a researcher wanted to use AI to control a fluid, they had to build their simulation entirely from scratch.
Like reinventing the wheel every time.
Exactly. They'd hand tune their neural network to one specific geometric shape at one specific flow speed using one highly customized piece of code.
I sort of think of it like trying to teach someone how to drive. But they are only allowed to practice in like a 1998 Honda Civic only on a specific Tuesday in one specific empty parking lot.
Right. And if they try to drive a truck on a Wednesday, they just crash.
They crash. And worse, they can't even compare their driving test score with anyone else because nobody is taking the same test.
So nothing accumulates.
Exactly. Nothing accumulates. And that is what HydroGem is attempting to blow up. It is a solver-independent platform offering over 60 validated, openly available flow control environments.
And those environments span an enormous range of physics, which is the key here. They include simple, canonical, two-dimensional laminar flows, and they move all the way up to complex, three-dimensional, turbulent ones.
Right.
We're looking at Reynolds numbers progressing up to 4 times 10 to the 5th. They incorporate variations in Mach numbers, covering both compressible and incompressible flows in two and three dimensions.
It's an entire shared infrastructure.
Yes. Designed to finally let researchers compare their A.I. agents apples to apples.
So before we get into the wild results they got to understand why a shared environment is such a big deal, we kind of need to look backward for a moment at how machine learning was already being used in physics before HydroGym.
Because people were definitely using A.I. for fluid mechanics.
Right, but they were essentially walking down two completely different paths, right?
Yeah, two major directions. The first path was focused on learning the controller. You can look at the 2020 work by Brunton, Nowak, and Komutsakos as a really good benchmark for this.
And in those scenarios, the AI is basically trying to find the best physical strategy to manipulate a flow, like opening a valve or rotating a cylinder.
Precisely. Now the second path, which gained a ton of momentum slightly later, was learning the solver itself.
Which means using AI to actually do the math of the fluid simulation faster rather than trying to physically control the fluid.
Right. That's the big distinction. A prime example of that solver path is the 2021 paper by Kochkov and colleagues. They trained a neural network to understand the underlying physics well enough that it could simulate 2D turbulence like 40 to
80 times faster than a traditional supercomputer.
Just doing the Navier-Stokes equations line by line.
Exactly.
Okay, so path one is the AI playing the video game, and path two is the AI acting as the game's graphics engine.
That's a great analogy. And HydroGym is squarely focused on the controller side, teaching the AI to play the game better.
And the authors point to DeepMind's 2022 Nature paper by DeGrave as their primary inspiration, right?
Yes, there was a watershed moment. That's the famous paper where DeepMind used reinforcement learning to magnetically control tokamak plasmas for nuclear fusion.
Which is mind-blowing on its own.
It really is. A tokamak plasma is basically a fluid made of superheated charged particles. Controlling it means managing chaotic real-time physics in an incredibly high-dimensional space.
So when DeepMind succeeded, the fluid mechanics community saw a proof of concept.
Exactly. If reinforcement learning could stabilize a fusion reactor, it could theoretically stabilize the wake behind an airplane wing.
Which brings us to a very bold claim the authors make in this new paper. They explicitly state that HydroGym represents an ImageNet moment for fluid mechanics.
Yeah, that's a heavy comparison.
Right. For context, ImageNet was that data set released in 2009 by Deng and colleagues. Millions of standardized labeled photographs that basically kicked off the modern deep learning boom in computer vision.
It transformed the entire field.
It did, but I really struggle with that analogy here because does releasing a benchmark actually cause a field to leap forward or does it merely measure progress that was already happening? And fundamentally, is a dynamic fluid simulation really the same kind of object
as a static JPEG of a golden retriever?
What's fascinating here is that you're highlighting the exact reason hydrogen is such a massive undertaking. The authors know a static image is different.
Right, because an image doesn't fight back.
Exactly. If an AI misidentifies a picture of a cat, the cat doesn't change shape. But HydroGym is an interactive closed-loop sandbox. It's
dynamic.
Highly dynamic. When a reinforcement learning agent decides to blow a jet of air into a virtual wind tunnel, the fluid instantly reacts. Vortices shift, pressures change, and the AI has to deal with the consequences of its own actions, like a fraction of a second later.
So the AI isn't just learning pattern recognition. It's being forced to learn the underlying rules of cause and effect in a totally chaotic system.
Precisely why an image net for fluids is so much harder to build.
Well, let's get into how they proved this platform actually works, because the computational sheer force involved here is just staggering. They didn't just release the code and walk away.
No, they put in the work.
They spent over 150,000 GPU hours just validating baseline performances. I mean, 150,000 GPU hours is roughly equivalent to leaving a high-end gaming computer running at max capacity for 17 straight years.
It's a colossal amount of compute.
And they used industry standard reinforcement learning algorithms, right? Things like proximal policy optimization or PPO.
Yeah, PPO, deep deterministic policy gradient DDPG, and twin delayed DDPG or TD3. These are algorithms that learn essentially through relentless trial and error.
So why spend all that time on the baselines?
The intention was to prove that standard off-the-shelf AI agents could actually learn meaningful control strategies inside these environments without needing custom hand-holding algorithms.
And the strategies that AI developed are honestly fascinating. Let's look at how it handled different scales of chaos. They start with a setup called the fluidic pinball.
Right. Running in a Reynolds number of 100.
And just to clarify, Reynolds number is a dimensionless way to describe how turbulent a fluid is. So 100 is very low. It behaves more like pouring thick syrup than splashing water.
Exactly. The setup here is three cylinders arranged in a triangle. The fluid flows past them and naturally creates these alternating irregular vortices in the wake.
And the AI was given the ability to rotate the cylinders.
Yes. And what the RL agents discovered through your interaction was this strategy of counter-rotation. They learned to continuously rotate the two rear cylinders in opposite directions.
And that actually worked.
Oh, it worked incredibly well. By doing that, they achieved a roughly 90% reduction in drag.
Wait, 90%. Let's unpack the physics of that. How does spinning a cylinder magically erase 90% of the drag?
So drag in this scenario is largely caused by the low pressure zones created by those spinning vortices in the wake. They essentially suck the cylinders backward.
Okay, that makes sense.
So by counter-rotating the rear cylinders, the AI injected momentum directly into the center line of the wake. This physical action prevented the separated layers of fluid from folding in on themselves.
So without that interaction, the vortices simply couldn't form.
Exactly. The AI essentially smoothed out the wake by using the fluid's own momentum against it.
Wow. OK, but that's a relatively simple static structure. What happens when the environment has a feedback loop? Because they move to a setup called an open cavity, right?
Yeah, running at a higher Reynolds number, 4,200 in 2D and 7,500 in 3D.
So now we're getting into fluid that behaves more like water rushing out of a tap. And cavity flow is notoriously difficult because of acoustic resonance.
It creates this self-sustaining chaotic loop. Yeah. The fluid flows over the open cavity and the shear layer, which is the boundary between the fast-moving fluid above and the slow fluid inside, becomes unstable.
So vortices roll up, travel across the opening, and basically smash into the back edge of the cavity.
Right. And that impact creates an acoustic pressure wave that travels back upstream, which then triggers more vortices to form.
It's the same physical mechanism that makes a sound when you blow over the top of an empty glass bottle.
Exactly. Just much more violent.
And a major driver of that violence is the Kelvin-Helmholtz instability. If you've ever looked up at the sky and seen clouds that look exactly like breaking ocean waves, you've seen a Kelvin-Helmholtz instability.
Yeah, it happens when two fluids are sliding past each other at different speeds.
So the AI was tasked with stopping this. It couldn't rotate anything this time. It could only blow or suck air at the edges of the cavity.
And the agent developed a strategy of highly coordinated blowing at the upstream edge. By injecting fluid right where the shear layer begins, the AI artificially thickened the layer.
Why does thickening it help?
Because a thicker shear layer is physically more stable, it acts almost like a shock absorber. This targeted thickening completely suppressed the Kelvin-Helmholtz instability before the waves could even form.
So it entirely broke that acoustic feedback loop.
Yes. It essentially softened the blow before the turbulence could spiral out of control.
That is wild. But that brings up another constraint researchers often face. You can't always just pump endless new air into a system, which leads to their demonstration on a circular cylinder at a Reynolds number of 3,900.
Right, where they applied a strict zero net mass flux constraint.
Meaning if the AI wants to blow a liter of air out of one jet, it has to simultaneously suck a liter of air back in through another jet.
Exactly. This forces the agent to manage the flow using only localized momentum transport. It can't cheat by just blasting the wake away.
So what did it do?
The AI learned to pair suction on one side of the cylinder with blowing on the opposite side.
I honestly find this to be the most compelling visual in the paper. The AI used the suction to pull the fluid tight against the surface, delaying separation, and used the blowing to push fluid into the weight.
Created a fluid shield, basically.
Yeah. It's as if the AI built a virtual, time-varying geometry out of thin air, perfectly managing the aerodynamics without the physical shape of the cylinder ever actually changing.
It actively reshaped the aerodynamic profile using nothing but pressure. And it had to do this continuously, adapting to the wake second by second.
Which perfectly transitions to the final demonstration, the NNAC-8000112 airfoil at a Reynolds number of 1,000. Here, they threw a curveball. They simulated a transverse gust of wind hitting the wing.
Right. Up until now, the setups were somewhat steady. This gust forces the AI to react to sudden external environmental changes.
Because a rapid change in wind direction causes the boundary layer on a wing to separate violently.
Yes, resulting in severe load fluctuations. It's what a passenger on a plane would feel as sudden heavy turbulence.
So the AI controlled three tiny jets on the leading edge of the wing.
And when the gust hit, the AI used those jets to dynamically inject momentum right into the separating boundary layer. It essentially synchronized its own localized vortex shedding to counteract the incoming gust.
And that worked.
It reduced the load oscillations by about 20%. It learned how to actively ride out the turbulence.
But as impressive as these four demonstrations are, they highlight a massive bottleneck. Standard trial and error reinforcement learning is brutally slow. I mean, spending 150,000 GPU hours to learn these tricks isn't practical for rapid iteration.
No, not at all. So the HydroGym researchers built in tools to change how the learning itself happens. This is a vital part of the platform.
They aren't just providing the sandbox. They are providing faster ways to play in it.
Exactly. The paper makes a strong argument for the superiority of differentiable physics, specifically through an algorithm they implemented called gradient-enhanced PPO, or GBPO.
Okay, let's break down what differentiable physics actually means. In standard model-free reinforcement learning, the AI is effectively blindfolded, right?
Pretty much. It turns a dial, waits to see if the drag goes up or down, and guesses what to do next based on the result. It has no underlying knowledge of the system.
And that trial and error approach requires millions of interactions.
But if your fluid solver is differentiable, the AI isn't blind-sold it anymore. Differentiable means the underlying mathematics of the simulation are written in a way that allows you to calculate the exact gradients.
Which are the precise sensitivities of the fluid to every possible action.
Right. It's the difference between trying to beat a video game by randomly mashing buttons until something works versus having access to the game's source code so you know exactly which line of code controls the boss's health bar.
You can mathematically calculate the most direct path to the solution.
Exactly. They tested this GPPO approach on something called a chaotic Kolmogorov flow.
Remind me, that's a highly chaotic mathematically forced flow, right?
Yes, it's used specifically to study turbulence without the distraction of physical boundaries like walls or cylinders. By back-propagating the loss function directly through that differentiable solver, they cut the required training iterations by at least 65%.
That is massive. So the takeaway is clear. If you can get the gradients from your simulation, differentiable physics beats model-free sampling every time. Absolutely. But even with gradients, simulations get too heavy. When they tackled a fully three-dimensional cylinder, they didn't
use one massive AI brain. to try and control the entire flow field.
The dimensionality is just too high for that.
So instead, they used a multi-agent setup. They took the 3D cylinder and decomposed it into local cooperating pseudo environments, each managed by its own smaller AI agent.
Which is a structural necessity for scaling up. And we should point out that this specific multi-agent approach builds directly on a predecessor paper from 2025 by Suarez and colleagues.
Right, which achieved roughly a 9% drag reduction on a similar 3D cylinder setup at Reynolds 3900. And it is important to be precise about the academic lineage here. Ricardo Venuesa is a co-author on both that 2025 Suarez
paper and this new August 2026 Hydrogen paper.
Right. So we aren't looking at a turf war between rival labs.
No, we're watching a research group systematically debug and refine its own methodology. So how does this new paper differentiate itself from that 2025 baseline?
The critical innovation is how those agents communicate. In the new approach, they utilize shared gradient updates and a unified replay buffer across all the agents.
Let's translate that. A replay buffer is basically the AI's memory bank of past experiences.
Right. Previously, agents might learn in isolation. So one agent figures out a good trick for its specific section of the cylinder, but the other agents have to discover that trick on their own.
But a unified replay buffer means they share a collective memory.
Exactly. If agent number three tries a specific JIT pulse and it drastically reduces local drag, agent number seven instantly learns from that success. They are mathematically sharing their updates, which makes the cooperative learning vastly more efficient.
OK, we've explored the environments, the speed ups and the cooperation, but we need to dedicate serious time to the headline result of this paper. The researchers attempted something called physics guided zero shot transfer.
It is easily the most provocative and consequential claim in the entire study.
I'll admit, when I first read the section, I assumed there was a typo in the data. Here is the setup. As we've established, training in A.I. directly on a complex curved 3D wing takes an agonizing amount of computing power.
The geometry is just too complicated.
So the researchers took a wild shortcut. They trained their multi-agent AI exclusively inside a cheap, canonical, turbulent channel flow at a friction Reynolds number of just 206. And a
channel flow is essentially just fluid moving between two flat parallel plates. It's a straight hallway. It's cheap, computationally light, and very well understood.
So the agent spends its entire training phase learning how to manipulate the flow in that simple flat hallway.
Yes.
Then the researchers take that fully trained AI, and with zero further training, no fine-tuning, no practice laps, they deploy it directly onto a three-dimensional Anaki 00012 wing section operating at a cord
Reynolds number of 200,000.
The leap in physical complexity there cannot be overstated.
I mean, 200,000 is equivalent to a small drone or a large bird in fast flight. Right.
A flat channel at Reynolds 206 has a uniform pressure gradient. A curved 3D wing at Reynolds 200,000 has massive surface curvature, inhomogeneous boundary layer development, and wildly varying pressure gradients as the air
accelerates over the top of the wing.
And yet the zero-shot transfer worked. The AI, which had never seen a wing in its digital life, cut local skin friction on the wing by 38%. It dropped total aerodynamic drag by 11%.
Which is incredible.
To put that in perspective, it beat out uniform blowing and it beat opposition control, which has historically been the gold standard.
And opposition control is a very rigid, classical method. You put a sensor slightly above the surface of the wing to detect the velocity of a turbulent fluctuation. Yeah. And you instruct a jet on the wall to blow fluid in the exact opposite direction to cancel the wave
out.
Like noise-canceling headphones for turbulence.
Exactly. The fact that the AI beat that standard without ever practicing on the wing is remarkable.
And because they trained it in the cheap channel flow, the exploration cost dropped by more than four orders of magnitude and hodl wall clock time was slashed by roughly a factor of 60. Yes. But we have to ask the fundamental question here. How? How does an intelligence trained
entirely between two flat plates intuitively know how to fly a curved wing?
If we connect this to the bigger picture, it comes down to the underlying scaling of turbulence. On a macro scale, a flat plate and a curved wing look completely different. Right. But if you zoom in microscopically close to the surface into what fluid dynamicists call the inner layer,
the physics are strikingly similar. Both configurations share identical near-wall turbulence scaling.
So they both generate these high-speed and low-speed streaks of fluid right at the boundary.
Exactly. So the AI didn't memorize the shape of the room it was in.
Because if it had memorized the geometry of the flat channel, it would have failed catastrophically on the wing.
Exactly. What it actually learned was near-wall momentum transport. It learned to recognize the signature of a turbulent streak and exactly how much localized pressure to apply to attenuate it.
So a streak is a streak, whether it happens on a flat plate or a curved airfoil.
The policy learned the physics, not the geometry.
Which brings us to the philosophical framing the authors provide at the very end of the paper. They look at this successful zero-shot transfer and explicitly draw an analogy to large language models.
The architecture behind the AI chatbots we use today.
Right. They suggest this is the first step toward a foundation model for flow control.
And the comparison to LLMs is deeply intentional. Consider how a model like GPT-4 was built. It didn't achieve its generalization from one magic algorithmic breakthrough.
No, it achieved generalization because it was pre-trained on a standardized, large-scale, massive corpus of diverse human text. It basically read the whole internet.
So it learned the underlying grammar of language itself. And the authors are arguing that HydroGym is the beginning of that diverse pre-training corpus, but for the physical world.
Oh, wow. So if you expose a single AI to enough diverse fluid environments, laminar, turbulent, compressible, incompressible, varying Reynolds numbers, it'll eventually extract the universal governing equations of fluid dynamics.
Just like an LLM extracted the grammar of language.
is a stunning vision for the future of engineering. But as with all breakthroughs, we have to ground ourselves in reality. The authors themselves put their limitations in writing, and we need to talk about the massive gap between a supercomputer and, say, a Boeing 777.
The tension lies entirely in the scale of the simulations. Every environment inside Hydrogym utilizes direct numerical simulation, or DNS.
And DNS is mathematically pure, right? It resolves every single tiny turbulent eddy down to the smallest scale without relying on approximations.
Right. But doing that is computationally devastating. Because of that, hydrogen caps its internal flows near a friction Reynolds number of 2200. And its external flows, like the wing, at a chord Reynolds of 400,000.
And real-world industrial applications operate in a completely different stratosphere. Real aircraft and turbo machinery live at Reynolds numbers between 10 to the 7th and 10 to the 8th. We're talking about tens of millions.
And the paper explicitly notes that if you wanted to embed wall-resolved simulations inside an RL training loop for those real-world Reynolds numbers, the hardware requirements become science fiction.
You'd need more than 500 GPUs and over 50 terabytes of memory for a single run. Just to hold the data for one single snapshot of air moving over a wing, we just hit a hard wall of silicon and electricity.
We do. Furthermore, the zero-shot transfer worked beautifully because the channel flow and the wing shared that near-wall turbulence physics. But the authors openly admit that this remains unresolved for more complex phenomena.
Like what happens when the AI encounters strong adverse pressure gradients?
Or what happens when the flow massively separates from the wing? Or when an aircraft introduces compressibility effects and shock waves?
And the ultimate reality check. As of the publication of this paper, absolutely none of this has been tested in a physical wind tunnel yet.
That is the dividing line. Is this an ImageNet moment for fluid mechanics or a very good simulator whose results still have to survive contact with a real wing?
HydroGym finally gives researchers the shared platform they need to find out, but yeah, the final verdict will have to be written in the physical world. That is the perfect place to wrap up today's deep dive. We started by picturing the impossibility of controlling the wind. We aren't
quite there yet, but HydroGym proves that the path forward isn't just throwing more computing power at the problem in isolation.
It's about building a shared language and standardizing our tests.
Exactly. I want to leave you with a final thought to mull over. If the author's vision actually comes to pass, and we do build a true foundation model for fluid dynamics and intelligence that intuitively understands the physical world better than our traditional math does,
could we eventually use it to prompt reality? Imagine opening a terminal, not to ask for a recipe or a poem, but to type a text prompt asking for a vehicle shape that produces zero aerodynamic wake.
And the AI just designs a geometry that manipulates fluid in ways human engineers never even conceived of.
We wouldn't just be analyzing fluids anymore. We'd literally be programming them. Think about that the next time you hold your hand out the window of a moving car and feel the air push back. Thanks for joining us.